Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
(Langue inconnue)
En français :
Pourquoi pas ?
(Rit)
C’était quoi votre rêve à vous
quand vous aviez quatorze ans ?
Rencontrer votre idole peut-être ?
Ou bien changer le monde ?
Qui sait ?
Moi, je rêvais de devenir linguiste.
Je ne savais pas en quoi ça consistait,
ni ce que ça impliquait,
mais c’était ce que je souhaitais
faire au plus profond de moi.
À l’époque, madame Moreau,
ma prof de latin,
à qui je confie mon rêve de carrière,
me répond du tac au tac :
« Toi, tu regardes la série Stargate.
Tu veux faire
comme Daniel Jackson, c’est ça ?
Celui qui étudie les langues
des peuples d’autres planètes ? »
Je souris.
Elle avait raison.
Ce qu’elle ignorait toutefois, c’était que
mon ambition était un peu plus accessible.
Malgré tout, il m'aura fallu traverser
quelques océans pour y parvenir.
Venez, je vous emmène avec moi.
Tout a commencé le soir
du 29 mai 1999 à 21 h précises.
J’ai alors dix ans.
À la télé, avec mes parents, nous
regardons le concours de l’Eurovision.
Cette année-là, les pays participants
ont pour la toute première fois
le droit de chanter
dans la langue de leur choix.
Mais la Lituanie, première
à se présenter sur scène,
ne chante ni en anglais ni en lituanien,
comme on pourrait s’y attendre,
mais en samogitien.
Le samogitien est lui aussi
une langue parlée dans cet état balte,
mais par seulement 500 000 personnes.
(Chante en Samogitien)
(Samogitien)
La langue est infiniment mélodieuse.
Pour moi, c'est un éblouissement.
Je découvre qu’il existe
une diversité de langues, de sonorités,
qu’il existe même des peuples
parmi les peuples,
des minorités comme on dit.
Un monde s'ouvre à moi.
Alors sur l’ordinateur familial,
mes recherches s’orientent tout
naturellement vers les langues étrangères.
Et sur l’encyclopédie Encarta
qu’a installée mon père,
j’ai accès à des mots et à des expressions
dans plus de 90 langues.
On peut même les écouter.
Mon horizon s’élargit.
Et au fil de la liste que je déroule,
il y a des langues
comme le grec, le danois, le finnois.
Et puis, soudain, comme surgie
de mon imagination, l’Haida,
parlée sur les îles
de la Reine-Charlotte au Canada,
ainsi que dans
l’extrême Sud-Est de l’Alaska.
Le portrait qui est fait
de cette langue m’intrigue.
Elle serait composée - c’est écrit - de 46
consonnes pour seulement trois voyelles.
Intrigué, poussé par ma curiosité,
je décide de taper le mot « Haida »
sur un moteur de recherche
et je tombe sur cette carte :
la carte des peuples indigènes
d’Alaska et de leurs langues.
Mon regard se porte immédiatement
sur le tableau situé à gauche.
À côté du nom de chacune des 20 langues
parlées dans cet État américain,
se trouve le nombre de ses locuteurs.
Et à côté du nom Eyak - E Y A K -
il est écrit le chiffre « 2 ».
(Murmures dans le public)
(Rit)
Oui, vous avez bien compris.
Seules deux personnes au monde
parlaient alors l’Eyak.
Seulement, nous sommes en 2003
et notre carte a été publiée en 1982.
Le temps a passé.
En vérité, cette année-là,
il n’existe plus qu’une seule personne
au monde qui parle l’Eyak.
Il s’agit d’une femme, Mary Smith Jones.
Mary Smith Jones a 85 ans.
Pourquoi est-elle la dernière
de son peuple à parler l’Eyak ?
Et à quoi ressemble cette langue oubliée
sur le point de disparaître ?
Car c'est une claque pour moi.
Des langues vivent et des langues meurent.
Comme nous.
Ou plutôt avec nous, et, nous le verrons
plus tard, à cause de nous.
En France, nous avons le basque,
le breton, le picard et le corse
qui ont connu ou connaissent
encore une forme de déclin.
7000 langues sont parlées dans le monde.
Près de 1500 disparaîtront
dans les prochaines décennies.
L’Eyak, lui, est en sursis,
sur le bord du précipice.
Je découvre qu'il y a urgence.
Et pour moi, c’est instinctif :
il faut que je l’apprenne
par tous les moyens possibles.
On me demande souvent pourquoi.
Pourquoi ce choix ?
Sur le plan des émotions,
il y a des choses qui ne s’expliquent pas.
On est parfois portés
par quelque chose qui nous dépasse.
C’est comme un rêve, c’est insaisissable.
Le chemin s'ouvre à mesure qu'on avance.
Cette part de mystère qui constitue
la vie palpite aussi dans chaque langue.
Il y a des choses à déchiffrer, des choses
indéchiffrables, une part humaine immense.
La vitalité des langues dépend
toutefois des peuples,
de la bonne santé sociale
des peuples qui les parlent.
Une hégémonie, une guerre,
une interdiction de parler sa langue au
profit de celle de la majorité dominante,
et c’est tout l’équilibre
d’un groupe humain qui s’effondre.
On parle alors de génocide culturel.
C’est précisément
ce qu’a enduré le peuple Eyak.
Minoritaire parmi
les différents peuples d’Alaska,
il fut dans un premier temps oppressé
par ses voisins, puis par l’Empire russe,
pour être finalement négligé, redécouvert
et réduit au silence par les États-Unis.
Celles et ceux qui ont été réduits
au silence ont des noms.
Léna, Mary, Anna, Sophie, Mike, George.
Et aussi des histoires.
Sans eux, leur langue n'existe plus.
Mais sans leur langue,
existent-ils seulement encore ?
Isabelle Adjani, dont l’allemand
est la langue maternelle,
a dit quelque chose qui va vous parler :
« Quand on parle une langue étrangère,
les expressions de visage, des mains,
le langage du corps, changent.
On est déjà quelqu’un d’autre. »
Je verrai bien pour ma part,
en rencontrant les Eyak,
eux qui parlent désormais l’anglais,
s’ils sont devenus quelqu’un d’autre.
Le 21 janvier 2008,
Mary Smith Jones meurt.
Ce jour-là, l’Eyak devient
officiellement une langue morte.
Mais pour moi, il est hors de question
que ce statut soit définitif.
Il faut que les Eyak puissent
de nouveau parler leur langue
et je vais tout faire pour les y aider.
Le premier obstacle à franchir,
c'est l'anglais.
Tout ce qui concerne l’Eyak est écrit dans
cette langue que je maîtrise à peine.
Alors, tant bien que mal,
je décide d’adresser un courriel
à l’université
qui a publié notre fameuse carte.
Et je reçois une réponse dans la nuit.
Le professeur Speriash promet de m’envoyer
toute la documentation dont j’ai besoin
pour commencer à apprendre
l’Eyak par moi-même.
Quelques jours plus tard,
je reçois un colis
dans ma boîte aux lettres.
Il contient deux cassettes audio
et un livre.
Un livre de légendes Eyak compilé
par le professeur Michael Krauss,
le spécialiste mondial de cette langue
qu’il a étudiée auprès de celles et ceux
dont c’était la langue maternelle.
Un trésor pour moi.
Impatient, je file dans ma chambre,
je m’assoie sur mon lit.
Le magnétophone entre les jambes,
le livre ouvert entre les mains,
je lance l’une des deux cassettes.
(Eyak)
J’arrive à suivre la lecture
d’un texte en Eyak
en même temps que l’histoire m’est contée.
J'en ai les yeux qui brillent.
C'est l'aventure qui commence.
En 2009, j’ai 20 ans.
Mon intérêt pour l’Eyak intrigue beaucoup
Laura, une journaliste américaine
qui avait suivi la dernière locutrice
de l’Eyak dans tous ses déplacements.
Profitant d’un séjour en Europe,
elle souhaite me rencontrer en France.
Elle veut savoir
si mes intentions sont sérieuses.
Elle n'est pas déçue du voyage.
L’année suivante,
elle m’invite chez elle, en Alaska,
pour rencontrer le professeur
Michael Krauss chez lui à Fairbanks,
ainsi que les Eyak chez eux
sur leurs terres ancestrales.
Cette fois, c’est moi
qui ne suis pas déçu du voyage.
Michael Krauss, qui aspire
à finir de rédiger sa grammaire
et son dictionnaire de l’Eyak,
me prend sous son aile
et décide de m’enseigner cette langue
de façon complexe, mais très efficace.
Intellectuellement,
je suis épuisé mais heu-reux.
Au bout d’un an,
ayant obtenu les financements nécessaires
pour concrétiser son projet,
il me demande si je suis partante
pour l’accompagner travailler avec lui.
Je lui réponds oui, sans hésiter.
Comme une évidence.
Avec un simple baccalauréat en poche,
grâce à mon investissement et à
la confiance d’un savant ouvert d’esprit,
j’obtiens un poste de chercheur en
linguistique à l’université de Fairbanks,
statut normalement réservé
à un post-doctorant.
Je n’ai rien calculé.
Tout s'est organisé pour moi.
D’une certaine manière,
j’ai saisi ma chance, comme on dit,
tout en l’ayant provoqué.
La suite de cette aventure humaine,
c’est auprès des Eyak
qu’il faut aller la chercher.
Nous sommes un après-midi de juillet 2010.
Le ferry accoste dans le petit
port de pêche de Cordova,
au cœur d’une forêt primaire,
entourés de montagnes,
bercés par les vagues
de l’océan Pacifique.
Une carte postale.
À quai, de nombreux Eyak m’attendent.
Il y a Dune, solitaire et engagée,
Mona, spirituelle et animée,
Pamela, la sœur de Dune,
timide et bienveillante.
Tous enfants ou petits-enfants
de celles et ceux qui,
faute de pouvoir parler leur langue,
l’ont transmise au professeur
Michael Krauss pour la postérité.
Invité, je me mets en retrait,
à leur écoute.
Je ne veux ni m'imposer, ni les brusquer.
Certains me font part de leur envie,
de leur souhait d’apprendre leur langue.
Ils veulent la parler,
la faire vivre au quotidien.
Pour eux, c’est un peu
un devoir de mémoire,
une manière de faire vivre
ceux qui les ont précédés,
de faire de nouveau lien,
communauté.
Dans le cadre d’un atelier,
le premier atelier que nous organisons
avec Laura, la journaliste,
tous sont invités à se présenter,
à raconter leur vie et leurs envies
dans un premier pas
vers une réconciliation avec eux-mêmes.
L'émotion est palpable.
Certains laissent couler leurs larmes.
À cette occasion, Bill,
le fils de Mary Smith Jones,
me fait une confidence.
Sa mère, avant de mourir, a eu une
prophétie, un mot à l'égard de son peuple.
Elle leur a dit : « Mes chers enfants,
lorsque je mourrai,
notre langue ne mourra pas avec moi,
car quelqu’un viendra de très loin
pour vous l’enseigner. »
Il aura fallu qu’un obscur
jeune homme de 21 ans -
ce sont les mots de Mona -
viennent de l’autre bout du monde
pour leur dire la beauté de leur peuple,
la richesse de leur langue
et de leur culture oubliées.
J’ai alors compris la mission
qui était la mienne : enseigner.
Durant dix ans, les Eyak et moi, nous
nous sommes retrouvés chaque été.
J'ai développé des cours pour les adultes,
des jeux pour les enfants.
J’ai rendu accessible
cette langue réputée difficile.
Je la leur ai restituée.
Ensemble, ils l’ont parlée,
partagée et se sont amusés.
Ils y ont découvert la richesse de ce
qu’ils sont, une part de leur identité,
car leur langue les informe sur eux-mêmes.
À travers elle,
c’est leur culture qui leur est révélée.
Le nom des plantes, par exemple,
les renseignent sur leurs usages,
sur leur pharmacopée.
Leur connaissance du monde,
de leur environnement,
leur apparaît dans leurs métaphores.
Le rapport à l’altérité se manifeste
quant à lui dans la place du sujet.
En Eyak, le « nous » précède
toujours le « je ».
Chez eux, ni masculin, ni féminin.
Les noms sont classés
par forme et par matière.
Le Soleil éclipsé par la Lune
fait le mort,
tandis que les pellicules
que l’on a dans les cheveux
sont des écailles de poisson
que l’on a sur la tête.
Les mois de leur calendrier, quant à eux,
décrivent le cycle de la vie :
le retour du saumon royal, la fonte
des neiges, la mue des canards.
Dans le cadre d’un atelier,
soucieux de les voir enfin
s’exprimer dans leur langue,
de créer et de faire corps avec elle,
je leur ai proposé d’écrire un texte.
Je leur ai soumis une liste de mots
et je leur ai donné carte blanche.
Jane, la plus discrète de tous mes
élèves, nous a présenté un poème.
Un poème magnifique, très personnel,
qu’elle a lu avec fierté.
Rendez-vous compte : le premier poème
en langue Eyak du 21ᵉ siècle.
Tout le monde était ému, criant (Eyak) -
Super ! -
comme pour se féliciter collectivement
du long chemin parcouru.
Aujourd'hui, Jane, Garrett, Jenna, Judy,
Angela, Barbara, Bill parlent leur langue.
Une voix dans l'humanité
ne s'est pas éteinte.
Aussi, je vous invite
à ne jamais éteindre la vôtre.
Une langue, ce n’est pas
qu’un simple moyen de communication.
Une langue, c’est un musée vivant,
porteur d’une vision
et d’une description singulière du monde.
Mémoire d’un peuple et de son territoire
où chaque locuteur, chacun d’entre nous
est à la fois un usager
et un conservateur.
Nous la parlons, nous la faisons
vivre et nous la transmettons.
Chacun d'entre nous est aussi un créateur,
un artiste en puissance.
Ainsi, une anecdote racontée à des amis,
une déclaration d’amour,
une histoire du soir inventée
pour endormir un enfant,
tout cela, chacune de ces actions
du quotidien contribue à l’enrichissement
et à l'embellissement d'une langue.
Continuons à traduire en mots ce que
nous ressentons au plus profond de nous.
Nous parlons une langue unique,
intime, précieuse,
celle de nos émotions
et de nos aspirations.
Ne mettons pas en danger
notre singularité.
Protégeons-la et protégeons celle
des autres en les considérant,
en les écoutant.
Aujourd’hui comme hier,
je rêve le monde en Eyak.
Et vous, en quelle langue le rêvez-vous ?
(Applaudissements)